Hello. We're glad you've joined us
for this live webinar:
Don't Hesitate. Learn How to
Step Up Your Library Prep
with New Biomek i-Series Genomic
Sample Prep Workstations.
I'm Judy O'Rourke of LabRoots
and I'll be moderating this session.
Today's educational web seminar
is presented by LabRoots,
the leading scientific
social networking website,
and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning.
It's brought to you by Beckman
Coulter Life Sciences.
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences
develops, manufactures, and markets
products that simplify, automate, and
innovate complex biomedical testing.
More than 275,000 Beckman
Coulter systems operate
in both diagnostics and life sciences
laboratories in seven continents.
For over 75 years,
Beckman's products have been making
a difference in people's lives
by improving the productivity of
medical professionals and scientists,
supplying critical information
for improving patient health,
and delivering trusted solutions
for research and discovery.
To learn more about Beckman
Coulter Life Sciences,
please visit www.beckman.com.
Let's get started.
You can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind.
To do so, simply type
them into the Q & A box,
which will open when you
click the green Q & A button
at the lower left of the
presentation window.
Questions will be answered
after the presentation.
To enlarge the slide window,
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window.
If you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation,
just click on the support button
found at the top right of
the presentation window.
Or report your problem by clicking on
the green Q & A button at lower left.
I now present todays
speaker, Zach Smith,
a senior applications scientist
at Beckman Coulter Life Sciences.
In his role, Zach
automates proprietary
and third party next generation
sequencing, NGS kits.
He holds a masters degree
in Environmental Science
and a bachelors degree in Biology
from Indiana University.
Zach also worked at
the University Center
for Genomics and Bioinformatics
as a project scientist
before joining Beckman Coulter
Life Sciences in 2014.
Zach Smith will now
begin his presentation.
Thank you very much
for the introduction.
Thank you to everyone for joining
us today for this live webinar.
My name is Zach Smith and I'll be
taking you through innovations
that we have created
for NGS sample prep
on our Biomek i-Series platforms.
Just briefly, heres my disclaimer.
Obviously, all trademarks belong
to their respective owners.
For the outline today, we're
going to be going briefly
over the Biomek automated
i-Series Automated Workstation,
for those of you who did not attend the
first part of this three-part series.
And then I'll be taking
you on a case study
of automating biomarker
discovery from FFPE samples
using our Biomek i-Series
Automated Workstation
with our FormaPure DNA
kits that we sell,
and the Illumina TruSeq Exome kit.
So the i-Series represents an
expansion of the Biomek product line
that we're proud that we launched
this LES earlier this year.
Obviously, we have our Biomek 4000
at the very low end of our automation
offering, followed by the NX,
and then one of the previous
platforms is the FX.
We're proud to add the
Biomek i5 and i7,
and we're able to extend
these workstations
into larger integrated systems.
So we have the ability to
offer an automation solution
for a variety of different
users and throughputs.
The Biomek i-Series
Automated Workstation
offers a variety of new features
that will allow you for a
more simplistic workflow.
It allows you to increase
your efficiency,
improve your reliability and support,
and make the system more
adaptable to extend the scale
and reach of your research.
I' m going to be going over
each one of those major points
in the following few
slides very quickly
so that we can familiarize
ourselves with the platform.
So the i-Series Automated
Workstation comes in two sizes.
If you remember earlier, the i5,
which is sort of the mid-range size,
and the i7, which is
the larger of the two.
The i5 instrument comes with either
a span pod or a multichannel pod.
And with the i7, you can have a span,
a multichannel, a dual multichannel,
or a hybrid with one each.
So theres two platforms of six
different pipetting configurations
that are available in
these new systems.
The Biomek software, if you're
familiar with Biomek now,
there's about a 20 minute learning
curve for the new software.
So the software has been
redesigned to work on Windows 10.
Its been re-stylized, but again,
if you're familiar with our
current software,
you'll have no trouble transitioning
into our new software.
The other thing we've
added to the system
is a large status light bar on top,
which you can see glowing in
the dark on the bottom left.
That allows you to monitor the system
status from across the lab quite easily.
We've also added an
LED-illuminated deck
to improve visibility when loading and
unloading the instrument with labware
and allow you to watch
pipetting more effectively.
So it really is quite handy.
The systems have
improved deck capacity.
So the i7 has 45 deck positions
compared to approximately 20 on the FX.
The i5 has approximately
25 deck positions
compared with approximately
12 on the NX.
So you get a lot more
space in your deck.
The overall instrument footprint,
however, is not appreciatively larger.
So we're able to create
all that extra space
by making the deck more dense.
We now have a rotating
gripper on each pod,
which allows you to pick up labware
and move it around the
deck more efficiently.
So there's no position on the
deck thats not grippable now,
which is really handy.
Our multichannel head has
been completely redesigned.
So we actually use force loading now
for our tips on the multichannel pod,
so there's no more tip
loader on the deck.
We also offered selective tip loading
on the multichannel pod as standard,
which means you can load
anywhere from one to 96 tips.
For the span pod, we've introduced
individual probe calibration
to allow for more accurate
sub-microliter pipetting.
The deck itself is a
grid-based pattern,
so instead of having
one piece of metal
where you locate your ALPs
in very specific locations,
the deck plates are individually
located on the deck,
and then they have grids
built on top of them
so you can have more flexibility in
how you're laying out your system.
The other thing about
the new platform is
you'll notice how open the design is,
so that allows us to integrate devices
off the back and off the sides
more effectively.
So additionally, we offer
enclosures on these systems,
so they can come with the
built enclosure or without.
We also offer hepa for
the enclosure option.
We also have new on-board
cameras built into the towers,
which allow you to remote monitor
the instrument while it's running.
And if there is an error, Biomek will
retain up to 30 seconds of video
before and after the error to
allow you or one of our engineers
to identify what the
problem is and fix it.
Additionally, we're
offering our PROService,
which allows us to remote in to the -
assuming, of course, that your IT
department will allow us to do so -
allows us to remote in to the Biomek
controller and get the files we need
in case you need service of some
variety with an application,
or there's a particular software
question that you have.
And then obviously, we're maintaining
our current customer training program
and application support to get
you up and running.
Beckman Coulter works with
a wide variety of partners
and we have automation solutions
that help drive acceleration
in a number of different ways.
We have proactive method development,
so part of my job internally
is to go out and automate
our Beckman chemistry,
as well as third party chemistry
such as Illumina or NEB
on our Biomek i-Series.
So we do that proactively working
with the reagent vendors
to identify what kit that
they're seeing demand for
and get an automation
solution available
for those to help speed up
your work as researchers.
We also work with a
variety of companies
that work for cell-based assays.
Obviously, Beckman Coulter is a
member of the Danaher family,
along with ForteBio and SCIEX.
So we all work very closely
together as Danaher companies.
So that gives us options for a variety
of different integration collaborations.
For NGS, primarily it's us
working with the reagent vendors
for their nucleic
acid, NGS sample prep
and nucleic acid sample preparation.
So we also work with affymetrix as
well for microarray sample prep.
i-Series really does a lot for
helping expand your efficiency
and turnaround time for
method development.
The screen shot you see here
on the bottom of the slide
is basically a comparison sheet
between our current methods,
as they exist on the FX,
and what are time savings
and whatnots you would
achieve with the i-Series.
So for example, with Illumina
stranded mRNA, for the FX,
we have to do it in terms of there
is at least one manual deck reset
because of the deck capacity at the
end of seeding your synthesis.
Whereas that same method on the
i- Series i7 can be set up once
and completely walk away in
approximately eight and a half hours.
So you get increased ability to walk
away and better turnaround time.
We also have a method card that we can
certainly be happy to send to you
with what we've developed currently
and what we're in the process of
implementing on the i-Series.
With all that being said, I'm
going to dive into a case study
of automating biomarker
discovery from FFPE samples
using the i-Series
Automated Workstation
and our FormaPure DNA kits as well
as the Illumina TruSeq Exome kit.
The National Cancer Institute
defines a biomarker
as a biological molecule found
in blood or other fluids
that is indicative of a treatment
or disease conditions.
Biomarkers can take the form of DNA
variants, RNA variants, or proteins.
For DNA variants, they come
in a wide variety of flavors.
You can have single nucleotide
polymorphisms, insertions,
deletions, copy number variants.
So one of the things that researchers
really want to understand
is what is the molecular drivers of
cancer in this particular research area?
Another thing you'll find very
commonly in oncology is FFPE DNA.
FFPE stands for fixed formalin
paraffin embedded tissue.
Effectively what happens is when
you go in and have a biopsy done,
the tissue is fixed in formalin
and then embedded in paraffin.
And this allows the tissue sample
to be stored at room temperature
for decades fairly cheaply.
So it's incredibly easy to perform,
and it's quite economical as well.
It's just a few dollars per block.
Part of the difficulties of working with
it include difficult extractions of DNA.
The DNA is frequently damaged
due to a variety of things
including double stranded breaks,
deamination, and pyrimidine dimers.
And then you also get variable yield
due to an uneven distribution
of sample in the block.
So you don't necessarily know
when you're going through
and slicing the block into
your ten micron slices
where exactly that tissue
is going to be located.
Needless to say it's not everyones
favorite material for working with,
but it's what we have.
With that, Beckman Coulter just
recently released a new kit
called FormaPure DNA for
extracting DNA from FFPE material.
This is the entirety of the workflow.
So we take our slice and
we deparaffinize it
by heating it up in mineral oil.
We then add our lysis buffer
and Proteinase K
and digest the tissue away,
perform our decrosslinking by
heating the sample up some more.
And then we add our RNase A
to digest away all the RNA,
and then we use our solid phase
reversible immobilization technology
or SPRI beads to bind the
DNA, remove it from solution,
wash it, and then elute.
So as you can see, it's an
extremely compact workflow
and does not require any spin columns.
It generally works quite nicely.
So nine steps.
There's one optional centrifuge
step, no Xylene required,
and just three temperatures.
So it's not a terribly
complex workflow.
It makes it quite easy on automation
specialists such as myself.
So this is just some manual extraction
data that colleague, Jung Do,
who's the internal application
scientist for reagents generated.
So as you can see here,
compairing FP DNA to Supplier Q
yield with Horizon breast, lung,
large intestine, liver, and lung,
we were able to get
comparable or better yields,
both in terms of the quantity
of DNA that was isolated
as well as the quality of the DNA,
per nanodrop on the
chart on the bottom right.
The next question we
wanted to address
is because we had heard from a
variety of customers is well,
that's all well and good,
but what if I wanted to
do a split extraction?
What if I wanted to get DNA and
RNA out of the same sample?
So Jung went back and began
working on an expanded workflow.
So the split workflow is
shown here graphically,
but it's very similar to
the DNA only workflow.
We form the deparaffinization and
lysis and the protein SK treatment,
and then the lysate itself is
split into two different plates.
And then we proceed to go through
and do a DNA workflow on top,
and an RNA workflow on the bottom.
So we allow this to actually isolate
maybe total nucleic
acid from one sample.
This is some comparative RNA
yields comparing Supplier Q,
Supplier O, and Supplier A.
We also looked at the Peltier
orbital shaker on these
so you can see our RNA
yields are quite good
that we're getting from
stomach and from -
obviously, not as good from
breast or lung or liver,
but a lot of this is block dependent.
So I think the yields here
are certainly more than sufficient
for most NGS applications.
The other thing we've noticed,
or we've shown at a variety
of different locations,
not just our internal lab,
is that the RNA we're getting
is actually more intact
than RNA that's derived
from comparable kits.
So you can see here
these are bioanalyzer RNA
nanotraces of the RNA
that was derived from using
a FormaPure DNA kit.
The blue traces you're seeing
in each of the four images that
you're seeing here are from our kit,
and the red traces you're seeing
here are from Supplier Q's kit.
So as you can see,
we're actually getting
more higher molecular weight RNA
species with our chemistry,
which this is pretty exciting stuff.
The other thing we did is we
went through and verified
that the RNA we're using is
actually NGS compatible.
We actually ran through the manual -
we ran through, manually, the
Illumina TruSeq RNA Access kit.
So this is some more work that
was done by a colleague, Jung.
On my left, your right,
probably, side of the screen,
you'll see bioanalyzer traces of
various points of library prep
and then some sequencing metrics
that Jung generated in house
on our NextSeq platform.
As you can see, the insert link
distribution was pretty tight.
The majority of the sample was
coming to the coding region,
and our transcript coverage
was fairly uniform,
meaning that we're not biasing -
the library preparation isn't biased
towards one end of the
RNA or the other.
So that was some pretty solid data.
For my part, what I did was we
put together an entire workflow
utilizing our chemistry and our
liquid handler for the DNA extraction
from the FFPE blocks,
and utilizing the
Illumina TruSeq Exome kit
on our liquid handler for the
actual ingest library prep.
As you can see here, we can certainly
provide you with a section
and options through our fellow
op co at Leica with Microtome,
and then we also utilize the
molecular devices SpectraMax i3
for our four metric
assays for concentration,
we determined after
nucleic acid extractions.
So we did the block sectioning
on the Leica Mictrotome,
we then extracted the DNA using
our FormaPure DNA kit,
performed a QC of the DNA on
the liquid handler,
then did our library prep on
the same platform,
and then finally did NGS QC on
the platform as well.
So this is the deck configuration
of the instrument that I used
for this work.
This is a Biomek i-Series i7, dual
hybrid with a multichannel pod
and a stamp pod.
So the multichannel pod
in here, in this case,
has our new 1200 microliter
pipetting head on it.
It is also equipped with an
automated thermocycler, the ATC.
We also have the ability, incidentally,
to do a Biometra TRobot or Inheco ODTC
if you want additional walk away time
than putting your thermocycler
right on the deck.
And we also used a Beckman orbital
shaker and one Inheco static Peltier
for keeping our enzyme
master mixes cool.
So as you can see, the extra deck
capacity really does help a lot.
The other thing is these methods
that we've developed in house
is our Demonstrated Method Interface,
which is a three-part
software interface.
The first part of the software
would be our Biomek
Method Launcher offering.
What we've come to the realization
over the course of our last few years
is that the majority of our
users are operators,
they're not necessarily programmers.
And so Biomek Method Launcher was
designed to give our operators
the ability to just
go up to an interface
and select which method
they want to run
and not have to dive into the
complexities of the Biomek software
if they didn't wish to.
So they would go to the Launcher,
they would select from FormaPure DNA,
or they would select the NGS
application of interest,
and then number two, the Method
Option Selecter, would then pop up.
So this is where they're able to
go and configure the workflow
to match the number of
samples they're processing.
If they want to stop and
approve stop points,
this is where they would set that up.
And then once they've started the run,
then our Guided Labware
Setup will go through
and step them through where on the
deck to put all the tip boxes, plates,
and where to fill in
arrays and troughs
with the various
components that they need.
So this is really trying
to help the operators
come to the point where
they can go through
and set the instrument up with
confidence and reduced errors.
For our FormaPure DNA method,
I've got sort of a workflow
diagram up top.
For a manual protocol, we have
the dewax, lysis, decross,
nuclease treatment, bind,
two washes, and elution.
For the automation protocol,
we basically do all that as
one general workflow.
There is approximately 15 to
20 minutes of hands-on time
for setting the method up,
and then there are a variety of times
that you're seeing listed here.
So if you're running through
and doing the dewax, lysis,
and decross on deck,
that's approximately four
hours and forty-five minutes
for up to 96 DNA samples,
and one hour and thirty-three minutes
of the actual nucleic acid, bind,
wash, elute part of the method.
So effectively, you're looking at
about six hours and fifteen minutes,
approximately, for 96 DNA samples,
or six hours and thirty minutes
for up to 96 RNA only,
or if we were performing
a split workflow,
96 DNA and 96 RNA simultaneously
from the same sections.
So one technician with one Biomek
in approximately an hour and
a half of hands-on time
could do up to 500 samples a week
with the automation method
that we've developed
as it currently stands.
So, not too shabby.
For the biomarker experiment
that we performed here,
we had eight technical replicates of
Horizon HD200 reference materials.
This is the multiplex FFPE
reference material
that Horizon Diagnostics sells.
As well as five different FFPE
block samples from Asterand -
two breast, two lung, and a liver
at ages three to five years.
And we had four technical
replicates for each of those.
We had one ten micron curl for each
of those technical replicates.
So here's our FFPE DNA yields
as calculated from a PicoGreen
setup on the Biomek i-Series.
So Horizon samples, we had one
sample, Horizon number four,
where there was not as
much material in the tube
as there was the other samples -
but I went ahead and ran it anyway.
I don't know if they were
running to the end of the block
when they were sectioning that one.
As you can see, for all
the other samples,
we're getting well in excess of four
nanograms of double stranded DNA
out of each of our Horizon samples,
which was quite heartening.
Some of which were quite a bit
higher than 400 nanograms.
Then as you can see from
the rest of the samples -
76 of 96 were our lung samples.
Sorry, breast.
As you can see here,
theres quite a bit of difference
in the yields we're getting.
We see this all the time with
FFPE material, that there is -
going from section to section
and from block to block,
we can see quite a bit of
difference in yield.
For our breast and liver,
so breast was 110 and 121
and our liver was 107.
Again, we are seeing some
variability in the yield,
but certainly more than enough
for what we need to do for
our NGS library prep.
We also looked at a few
of the technical replicates
on the Agilent tape stations.
This is a genomic tape -
genomic screen tape
that was run on our Agilent 2200.
As you can see here, our
Horizon sample obviously had
the highest DNA integrity
number at 9.6,
but that's not terribly surprising
given that Horizon material
is not terribly old
by comparison to the
rest of the samples,
and it's probably been fixed
in a more gentle fashion
than the Asterand blocks.
So our DNA integrity numbers
for the remaining samples
were running from 2.2 to 3.6,
but obviously, more than
enough material to go through
and do our library prep on.
In a separate experiment, we're
looking at the split protocol.
So this was doing the FFPE DNA and
RNA on the Biomek i-Series system.
So we have the DNA yields,
and a size distribution
of the DNA on top,
and then for the RNA, we have
the yields on the bottom
as well as the sides distribution.
So this is some very early access data
we just developed
this a few weeks ago.
More work to come on this
particular application,
but just to show that we can do it.
TruSeq Exome, for anyone who is
familiar with the workflow,
it's a much more complicated workflow
than our extraction chemistry.
You start out with a DNA
fragmentation at cleanup
followed by end repair and
size selection,
atailing adapter ligation,
PCR and post-PCR cleanup,
and that sort of section one up
to the end of library construction.
Then you quantify the
individual libraries
and you pull them for your
hybridization capture,
and then theres two rounds
of hybridization capture,
followed by enrichment PCR
and enrichment PCR cleanup.
Our automation method
basically divides those
into three major sections.
On the first day,
you would run a section one
and get that up through your end
of library construction.
And then section two you
would run on day two,
going into the second hybridization,
which requires a minimum of 14 and
a half hours of hybridization.
And then section three is what you
would finish up on the third day,
and then the times for processing
up to 96 samples or eight pools
is included in the bottom as well
as some setup time estimates.
Obviously, I didn't include
the hybridization times
because those were run off-deck.
As far as the hybridizations
are concerned,
that's not really something
we recommend running
with the on-deck
thermocyclers generally
because the evaporation might
become quite a bit of an issue.
For our experiment, we had basically
four six plex pools we were running.
Pool 1 included all of our FFPE
samples as well as one Horizon spike.
And in the other three pools,
we replaced the box 76 technical
replicate with Promega genomic DNA
just to test the workflow,
to give it some -
you know, this is what pristine
DNA would look like
when run through the automation.
There were some protocol deviations,
so Illumina did publish a tech note
for working with FFPE material
with this kit.
So we did use 300 nanograms
of FFPE DNA input for the library
construction as opposed to 100.
Utilized 12 cycles of PCR for
the library amplification
and 500 nanograms of library going
into hybridization capture.
So those are all per
Illuminas recommendations.
Here we see some library traces,
and the final library yields
that we're looking at for
our individual libraries.
As you can see on the right, we're
seeing a genomic DNA library,
one of the Promega
genomic DNA libraries,
and then on the left, we're
seeing our FFPE libraries.
So we had slightly higher adapter
divers in the FFPE libraries
compared to the genomic library,
but that is to be expected
given some of the challenges
in working with FFPE material.
It doesn' t necessarily ligate
as well or readily
or amplify as readily
as our genomic DNA
due to the various bits of damage that
occurs during the fixation process.
But our library yields were more
than sufficient for going forward
into library construction, or
the hybridization capture.
The traces you're seeing on
this slide are our two pools,
so we took two of the six plex pools
in through hybridization capture -
Pool 1 and Pool 2.
The traces are on the left.
A qPCRs yield calculated on
the right were quite high.
More than enough material
to go into sequencing.
In our internal applications
lab here in Indianapolis,
we have both a NextSeq and a
MySeq sequencer from Illumina,
which is extremely handy for
generating sequencing data.
We don' t have to rely on a vendor
or an outside source to do so.
So we did a single NextSeq run
with a two by 76 paired-in kit.
We generated approximately
114 million reads
with 96 percent of the reads were higher
being path filter and identified.
We then took the reads and used
the BaseSpace Enrichment 3.0 app,
which uses the Aligner liner
and a variety of other
biogrammatics programs
to map the reads to the reference
genome and to provide
on target read enrichment numbers.
So this is the data that
you're seeing here.
In each of the samples
that constitute Pool 1 -
so we only sequenced one pool
in order to get fairly decent depth
of coverage on our one NextSeq run.
Our percent read alignments were
over 90 percent in all cases.
Our percent padded read enrichment
was approximately 60 percent
for all samples.
Padded read enrichment is
the percent of the reads
that are falling within the designated
regions of the TruSeq Exome kit.
I think there are
approximately 214,000 regions
that are covered in that kit.
So we would use the depth
file from Illumina
to calculate how many of our map reads
were falling into those regions.
Of the regions that are in the kit,
approximately 99 percent of
them were covered end-to-end,
at least to 1x, as you can see
from the graph below.
So that meant that we had fairly
uniform coverage of our regions,
and that's again
underscored by the graph,
the uniformity of coverage graph that
you're seeing on the right here.
This is looking at where the
reads are mapping on average
for each of the regions,
and we're seeing
uniformity of coverage
greater than 90 percent per that data.
Another thing we looked at was the
mean region depth of coverage.
So the Horizon sample performed the
best with almost 200x coverage.
We did see somewhere
around 50x coverage total
for the breast and the lung,
and approximately 100x
coverage for the liver sample
on average across all the regions.
When we looked at the targeted
region depth of coverage
and broke it down by 1x,
10x, or 20 to 50x coverage,
the Horizon sample obviously
outperformed all of them.
So 90 percent of the regions
were covered at 50x or higher.
The liver sample
performed the next best
with approximately 70 percent
of the regions covered at 50x or higher.
The other samples you
can see there as well.
I believe if we had more sequencing
coverage from MySeq runs
or additional NextSeq runs,
we could've driven these
numbers up substantially.
Another thing we wanted to look at
was what are some of
the SNVs we're seeing
in each of these samples.
So we looked at the metrics coming
off of the TruSeq Enrichment app,
and we generated, compared with
the reference genome,
anywhere from 28,000 to
65,000 SNVs that we observed.
The most important thing I
wanted to draw your attention to
is this SNV transition to
transversion ratio.
So there's some work that comes
up at the Broad Institute
that suggests, for a whole
exome experiment,
part of that ratio should
be approximately 2.8
as a way of measuring how well
your biogrammatics pipeline was
mapping the reads to the whole exome.
And as you can see here, we're
running anywhere from 2.6 to 2.8,
so I feel like the assembly that
we did of the reads,
the reference genome, using the
BaseSpace Enrichment 3.0 app,
did a fairly good job of
aligning them properly
and we're not seeing artifacts
based on the biogrammatics
part of the pipeline.
Another thing we looked at -
because we had a Horizon
sample on deck -
was the Horizon sample has
an expected allele frequency
that they publish on their
website for these samples,
which is extremely handy.
It allows you to verify
that your pipeline for both nucleic
acid extraction and for NGS sample prep
is actually observing
the allele frequencies
that you should expect to observe
for a variety of different markers.
As you can see here,
we did quite well as far as comparing
to our expected allele frequencies,
compared to what we were able to
identify with the Enrichment v3 app.
We did have a couple of dropouts.
Those were in EGFR, but
those were both less than -
the expected allele frequency
on the Horizon sample
was less than two percent
for these samples.
I feel like if we had
additional sequencing coverage,
that we would be able
to pull those out.
Additionally, we looked at the
parental line known mutations.
We were able to identify 17 of
the 19 parental line mutations
were also detected from our data,
even though this was a fairly
limited NextSeq sequencing run.
So I feel like, as far as being
able to find what is there,
we're on target.
Finally, we also looked
specifically at the liver sample.
The liver sample was
identified from Asterand
as being biliary tract carcinoma.
So biliary tract carcinoma is
a cancer of the bile ducts
that generates extremely small,
easily metastasized tumors.
Because it's buried
deeply within the liver,
it's very hard to detect.
I went into Cosmic, the compendium
semantic mutations and cancer
and pulled out the top 20 genes
were mutations of which were
associated with biliary tract cancer.
Of those, we were able to
identify the top seven,
as you can see on the
pie chart on the right,
including a number of mutations
identified in KMT2C,
which is a mental transference gene
that has been associated with this
particular variety of cancer.
Our TP53 mutation actually generated
a very short and truncated
version of the P53 protein,
so it's not surprising that
this tumor grew very rapidly.
But we were able to identify,
even from our limited
amount of NextSeq data,
mutations that were diagnostic
of the type of cancer
that the pathology
department had assigned
to that particular variety of cancer.
So yeah, it was a fun experiment.
So with that,
I want to acknowledge my colleagues
here at Beckman Coulter,
including Shilpa Parakh,
who is also a next generation
applications development scientist
like myself.
And Kathy Munkvold, Li Liu, Asmita
Patel, Amy Yoder, and JP Palys,
who are all members of our
internal development team
for the FormaPure DNA kit,
as well as Alisa Jackson, who is
our genomics automation manager.
With that, I will be happy to
take your questions.
Thank you very much for attending.
Thank you, Zach, for
your presentation.
A quick reminder for our audience
on how to submit questions.
Simply type them in the Q & A box
found by clicking on
the green Q & A button
at the lower left of the
presentation window.
Zach Smith will answer as many
questions as time permits.
And our first question is,
"are all of your demonstrated methods
available with i-Series instruments?"
So that's a great question.
We are in the process of moving
our demonstrated methods
over to the i-Series platforms.
There's been a number of changes
to the hardware and the software.
So, for example, the software for
the i-Series runs on Windows 10,
and the current Biomek
runs on Windows 7.
So there's a software challenge there.
And then there's the increased deck
capacity and the new grippers,
for example, of the new platform.
That is really giving
us an opportunity
to look at our current
demonstrated methods
and take advantage of all the new
capabilities we have on the i-Series.
Can we make the method faster?
Can we make it process more samples?
Can we reduce the
number of interactions
the user needs to do
with the instrument
in order to get a complete
workflow on the deck?
We are in the process of building out
that demonstrated portfolio
for the i- Series right now.
And we'll be happy to talk
about any specific methods if
you would want to contact us.
Next question is, "Can I use
FormaPure DNA for RNA isolation?"
Yes, you can.
As we covered in the slide deck,
we do have an extraction workflow for
extracting RNA from FFPE material
using our FormaPure DNA kit.
"Can you provide an example
where an NGS method is shorter
or has fewer touchpoints
on an i- Series instrument
compared to current Biomek platforms?"
Yes, I certainly can.
So with Illumina stranded
mRNA, for example,
right now on our FX, there's
a mandatory deck reset
at the end of CVN synthesis,
and then you go through and do the
remainder of the library preparation.
For the Biomek FX, that
whole method runtime
is approximately ten and
a half hours or so.
Putting the same method on the
i7, we have enough deck space,
we can put everything on the deck
that we need for the entirety
of library construction
from starting with your RNA
all the way through to the end,
the final enrichment PCR step.
Because of the extra capacity and
whatnot of the multichannel head,
we're able to do that
entire 96 sample workflow
in about eight and a half hours.
So we've saved one touchpoint
and approximately an hour and
a half of processing time.
"Has other Beckman software,
SAMI, DART, been updated
to work with the i-Series instruments?"
Yes.
In addition to Biomek,
we also have DART and
SAMI have been updated
to work with the new
i-Series platforms.
For those of you who aren't familiar,
DART, our data acquisition
and reporting tool,
allows you to take data in and out of
Biomek software from a limb system.
Best way to think about it is
the front porch of your limbs.
So if you want to be able to move data
in and out of the DART
repository between methods
as the instrument is processing,
that's perfectly fine with DART.
And then SAMI is our larger
scheduling software.
So if you wanted to run multiple runs
and you wanted to be able to
schedule them efficiently,
basically runs inside of incubations
while - basically start a method
and then run another method
inside that incubation period,
or if you wanted to schedule multiple
runs across multiple instruments,
SAMI would be your one.
So yes, it's all been updated
to run on the new i-Series
software and instruments.
"Say a variant is not detected,
do you have to assume the possibility
that that variant to be less than two
percent and find another method?
Or just throw away that gene info?
Or was the example set
up to show this anomaly?"
So generally, for samples
coming from Horizon,
I tend to believe that
the variants are there
when Horizons QC department
says that they're there.
If the variant falls below two
percent, maybe what you need to do is
you need to find a different NGS kit
that's sort of amplification based,
like TruSight Tumor 15
or 26, for example,
that allows you to do a
higher depth of coverage.
TruSeq Exome, because you're
sequencing in the entire exome,
is not really the best platform
for putting on the next seq
just because you're trying to
get a higher depth of coverage
over a much wider
region of the genome.
Maybe an amplification based NGS
application would be better
if you're hunting a small
subsection of genes
on a smaller sequencing instrument.
"What sort of equipment integrations
are available for i-Series platform?"
One of the things thats nice
about the new i-Series platforms
is the extra space we have
because of the open design
to allow for more integrations.
So we have - the plate washers,
we can put plate readers,
there are a couple of
integrated centrifuge options
that we can offer as well.
We can also integrate robotic arms,
so if you wanted to be
able to pass plates
in and out of different liquid
handlers, we can certainly do that.
We actually have an entire
department internally
whose job it is to integrate
third party devices
and make them work with our systems.
So we' d be happy to discuss
your instrument of interest
in more detail, if you'd like.
"Could you give some additional detail
on the depth layout for
library preparation?"
Certainly.
I'm just going to slide back
through the presentation real quick
because we've got a got a great
screen shot of the deck.
So this is the deck layout that
we're looking at right now
for sort of our standard NGS
deck for the Biomek i7.
We have the ability to put on
an integrated thermocycler.
In this case, it's the Thermo ATC,
which I have on my system in the lab.
And we have one static Peltier
in order to keep the enzyme master
mixes cool while they're on the deck.
We have an orbital shaker
as well for shaking -
basically, when you do an enzyme
addition, you'll shake the plate,
or if you're doing
bead cleanups as well,
we'll use an orbital shaker for that.
We also have a - not listed
here on the highlight -
but you also have a
multichannel wash stations.
So we have the ability to go through
and wash our tips if we want to.
I also use it for just waste dispense
for non-hazardous chemicals.
So we'll just dispense waste to there.
For those of you who are running LDTs
or sort of near clinical applications,
obviously, we can incorporate
our automated labware feeders
that would allow us to bring
more tip boxes onto the deck,
so we're not washing tips.
And then we have our seven
tip loader positions.
As I mentioned earlier, the i-Series
does not have a pneumatic tip loader
like the Biomex FX does.
We're basically just
using press loading
to load the tips for our multichannel
for these defined tip loader positions.
So you can have as many
of those as you want.
Its really convenient
because you don't have to -
if you have enough tip
loader positions,
you don't have to move the tip
boxes around to a location
and then wait for them to load.
You just load and go.
The other thing you'll see here is I have,
in addition to all that other stuff,
27 static positions for holding
tips for the Span-8 pod
and labware plates and reservoirs.
It really is a very nice system.
It's making me very lazy as
an applications developer.
Well, thank you.
I would like to once again thank
Zach Smith for his presentation.
Zach, do you have any final comments?
Well, just to thank you
all for your time.
I realize its been a little bit
of a whirlwind, but that's okay.
Thank you for hanging in
with us for this long,
and we'll be having another webinar
coming up in a couple days
on cellular applications.
And we hope you'll tune
in for that one as well.
Thank you.
Yes, please remember this
webinar is part of a series.
In the next webinar, scheduled
for Thursday, April 20th,
Mike Kowalski, PhD, will present
advances in cellular automation.
Registration is open on
the LabRoots website.
I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions.
Questions we did not
have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration.
We'd also like to thank our sponsor,
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences,
for underwriting todays
educational webcast.
This webcast can be viewed
on-demand through October 18th, 2017.
LabRoots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay.
We encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues
who may have missed todays live event.
Until next time, good-bye.